pragmatic question about the future do
you hope Donald Trump wins in 2024 and
how can his administration help bring
peace to the Middle East I think when
Donald Trump was President we had a
peaceful world everyone said if he was
elected we would have World War III
meanwhile he gets elected and he not
only is the first president in decades
to not start any wars he's making peace
deals he's making deals he's working
with our allies getting them to pay
their fair share in NATO he's uh you
know having a dialogue with China with
Russia he's weakening Iran and so I do
think that the job he did as a foreign
policy president was tremendous I think
um you know now more and more people are
starting to recognize that again under
President Biden this is the second war
that's broken down in the world and when
you have a weak American leadership the
world becomes a less safe place and so
uh My Hope and prayers are are that um
that that President Trump is reelected
and that he's able to then restore uh
order and calm and peace and prosperity
to the world from a place of strength
that's the only way he knows how to do
it what gives you hope about the future
of this region of
Israel and of the Middle East the Middle
East for 20 years
was an area of conflict uh uh they spent
all their money on bullets and bombs um
you have young leadership now in Saudi
Arabia and UAE and Qatar and there's a
much more ambitious agenda now for the
region to make it an economic superpower
and hub of the world Israel is one of
the most burgeoning and exciting Tech
economies in the world and if you think
about it it's almost like having uh
Silicon Valley not connected to
California the thing that's held the
region back for all these years has just
been the conflict and the division and
the lack of connectivity but if you have
that region and if it can all come
together if you can create a security
architecture you have an incredibly
young population you have a lot of
wealth and resources and a lot of
capabilities and and and knoow and so uh
I think that if it's managed correctly
and if Iran is is is able to be
restrained and and and suppressed with
their Ambitions to cause um
destabilization I don't mean Iran the
country I mean the Iranian regime
because actually once you have this
economic sphere if you could bring Iraq
into it if you could bring Iran into it
uh that makes it even bigger and
stronger and the Persian people are
incredibly entrepreneurial and
Incredibly industrious so I do think
that the region has tremendous potential
it's just been held back by bad policy
bad leadership bad objectives and again
you know when President Trump left
office in you know 200 um
2021 uh the Middle East was really on a
very very positive trajectory and if the
right things happen it can continue to
be so so you know I'm praying at this
moment in time that uh we navigate the
current crisis that the important
objectives are achieved of eliminating
the terrorists and their threats and
then allowing the leaders who are
focused on giving their citizens and and
their neighbors the opportunity to live
a better life are able to work together
and and and really dream and be
ambitious and find ways to create a
paradigm where human can
flourish